Steve!
It takes guts to drop out like you did.
Higher education comes at the expense of experience.
Woz!
What are you working on?
It's a computer terminal that hooks up to the TV for the display.
Steve?
Wow!
These are state-of-the-art.
Nobody's making anything like this.
Welcome to Apple Computer.
This is everything?
Sort of.
I think we should start with around 90 grand.
Could you repeat that?
If you'll have me aboard.
Apple Incorporated went public this morning.
We got to make the small things unforgettable.
Typeface isn't a pressing issue.
Get out!
He's trying to start a war with IBM!
Steve's been doing the impossible ever since he was in a garage.
I'm trying to build Apple and they're taking it away from me?
If you keep heading down this path, I will not protect you.
It's a blatant rip-off.
I'm going to sue you for every cent!
You are your own worst enemy.
The board is unanimous.
Steve will no longer be involved in this company.
Ten years after Steve Jobs' departure, the future of Apple Computer is in jeopardy.
In life, you'll only get to do so many things.
We're making Apple cool again.
Here's to the crazy ones,...
...the misfits,...
...the rebels.
Because the people who are crazy enough to think they can change the world...
...are the ones who do.
If we're going to do this thing, we need to come up with a name.
Apple!
That is so much better than Phaser Beam Computers.